COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I helped some IoT
visionaries come to terms
with Load Balancer performance.
Will their bet on the
future of technology payoff?
Stay tuned to find out.
IoT Roulette is a
company which offers
a scalable way for IoT
devices to connect with cloud
back ends through a common and
simple SDK and transport layer.
A few weeks ago, I
met with their CEO
to talk about the biggest
thing on her mind.
What's the performance overhead
of using GCP's load balancer?
As you can imagine,
scale is really
important to IoT Roulette.
With an estimated 50
billion IoT devices
in the world by 2020,
scaling your services
to handle the sudden load
of a million new devices
is an important feature.
So fast performing
load balancers
are crucial to get this right.
But before we start talking
about the balancers,
we need to see how
things perform directly.
To get a baseline
performance, we
set up an instance in US
Central and kicked off
a bunch of cURL commands
from a machine in Europe.
Now, if you do
this test yourself,
you'll notice that the
cURL performance can end up
being double what the
ping time is simply
due to the overhead of
TCP hand-shakes involved
and the transfer of
the fetched data.
Now, Google Cloud Platform
provides two primary load
balancers, so we
need to understand
the difference and profile
of each one individually.
The first is a TCP UDP
load balancer, which
acts much like you'd expect.
A request comes in from the
client to the load balancer
and is forwarded along
to the back end directly.
The HTTP load balancer,
on the other hand,
has some serious magic going on.
It proxies traffic through
Google front end servers
first, which stops the
session on the public internet
and continues on using
Google's private network.
So depending on which
balancer you're using,
we should expect a different set
of performance characteristics.
To test this, we set up instance
groups for each balancer
in the US Central region and
had a load generator in Europe
fetch from them using the
same cURL commands as before.
The results show some
interesting characteristics.
First, the TCP balancer
shows very similar results
to the direct access version.
This is somewhat expected.
In this case, traffic
moves from the user
to the load balancers, which
are in the region where
the VMs are located.
As such, performance is
a factor of the distance
from the requester to the
closest entry in the target
region, just like
directly accessing the VM.
The HTTP balancer,
on the other hand,
did something I really
wasn't expecting.
According to this
test, it appears
to outperform both the
direct connection and the TCP
balancer.
This is odd since the HTTP
load balancer effectively
adds another hop to each fetch.
Instead of going from the
client to the balancer
to the back end, it has
the intermediate step
of hitting the front
end boxes first.
Now, at first glance, this
seems confusing about why
adding an extra hop would
improve performance,
but once we look
under the hood, we
can quickly see why this works.
See, when a request
hits the HTTP balancer,
the TCP session stops there.
The GFEs then move the request
on to the private network,
and all further interactions
happen between the GFE
and your specific back end.
Now, here's the important part.
After a GFE connects to a back
end to handle the request,
it keeps that connection open.
This means that future
requests from this GFE
to this specific
back end will not
need the overhead of
creating a connection,
and instead can actually
just go to sending data ASAP.
The result of this setup means
that the first query that
causes the GFE to open a
connection to the back end
will see slightly
higher response times.
Those are the spikes in
the front of the graph.
However, subsequent packets
routed to the same back end
will see a lower
minimum latency.
So for IoT Roulette,
this is fantastic.
The more IoT devices
they get in a region,
the better their HTTP load
balancers will perform.
Not a bad bet to make.
If you'd like more
details on this problem,
check out the full article
linked in the description
below, and make sure to
subscribe to our Google Cloud
YouTube channel to get alerts
when new performance videos
comes out.
Because don't forget, when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]